THAT WE CAN AGREE ON.
GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS, TUCKER.
A FOX NEWS ALERT, BREAKING
MOMENTS AGO, U.S. FORCES JUST
LAUNCHED MULTIPLE TARGETED
AIR STRIKES AGAINST IRANIAN
BACKED MILITIAS.
THIS IN A DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE
ROCKET ATTACK THAT KILLED TWO
AMERICAN TROOPS AT A BASE IN
IRAQ.
MUCH MORE COMING UP TONIGHT, BUT
FIRST AT THIS HOUR, THE IMPACT
OF CORONAVIRUS IS BEING FELT
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE CANCELLATIONS, SCHOOL
CLOSURES, TOURNAMENTS CANCELED
FROM A PROFESSIONAL ATHLETIC
EVENTS CANCELED.
FOR SOME, THIS MIGHT SEEM LIKE
THE WORLD COMING TO AN END.
LET’S START WITH FACTS, NOT
FEAR.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, EVERY VIRUS AS
WE’VE BEEN TELLING YOU YOU MUST
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
IT HAS BEEN AN BEEN TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
AS A NATION, WE MUST TAKE EVERY
AND ALL NECESSARY PRECAUTIONS.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO BE CALM, WE
NEED TO BE STRATEGIC, WE NEED TO
BE SMART, WE NEED TO HAVE THE
RIGHT PERSPECTIVE.
ANY DEATH IS A TRAGEDY.
I SAID THIS BEFORE, MANY TIMES.
HEART DISEASE, MANY DISEASE, WE
LOSE IN THIS COUNTRY TENS OF
THOUSANDS PER YEAR EVERY YEAR
FROM THE FLU.
THIS IS A HEALTH CHALLENGE.
WE NEED TO RISE TO THE OCCASION
AS WE ALWAYS DO.
WE ARE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
THE WORDS "THE LAND OF THE FREE
AND HOME OF THE BRAVE" ARE NOT
JUST WORDS IN AN ANTHEM.
THOSE ARE WORDS ACCURATELY
DEFINE US AS A PEOPLE.
THIS IS A COUNTRY THAT BEAT BACK
THE FORCES OF NAZISM AND
COMMUNISM AND FASCISM AND
IMPERIAL JAPAN.
THIS IS THE COUNTRY THAT HAS THE
SINGLE BEST DOCTORS AND MEDICAL
RESEARCHERS ON THE FACE OF THE
EARTH.
THIS IS THE COUNTRY THAT ACUMEN
THEY DID MORE POWER AND ADVANCE
THE HUMAN CONDITION MORE THAN
ANY OTHER ECONOMIC SYSTEM
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD OR IN THE
HISTORY OF MAN.
SO TONIGHT, LIKE EVERY MAN IN
HIS PROGRAM, WE’LL BRING YOU
FACTS WITHOUT FEAR, WITHOUT THE
POLITICS OF PANIC RUNNING
RAMPANT IN THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU
PERSPECTIVE, CONTEXT, DATA,
INFORMATION, INFORMATION YOU CAN
USE TO PROTECT YOURSELF FROM
YOUR FAMILY, YOUR LOVED ONES.
MOST OF YOU WOULD SADLY YOU WILL
NOT GET FROM THE DERANGED AGENDA
DRIVEN MEDIA MOB.
LET’S START.
JUST 24 HOURS AGO,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HE WAS
DELIVERING A VERY SERIOUS
ADDRESS TO THE NATION.
HE OUTLINED NEW MEASURES
INCLUDING RESTRICTIONS ON
EUROPEAN TRAVEL ON TOP OF THE
BANDS ALREADY IN PLACE.
HE ALSO OFFERED FINANCIAL RELIEF
FOR THOSE IMPACTED.
INDUSTRY AND WORKERS AS WELL.
ALSO CALLED FOR UNITY, SAID, "WE
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER, WE
MUST PUT POLITICS ASIDE, STOP
THE PARTISANSHIP, UNIFIED
TOGETHER AS ONE NATION, ONE
FAMILY."
NEEDLESS TO SAY, IT DIDN’T TAKE
LONG FOR THE RAGE, THE HEAD,
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS ON THE
LEFT, THEY ARE NOT HEEDING THAT
ADVICE, SADLY.
FROM THEM, EVERYTHING, AND I
MEAN EVERYTHING, IS SEEN THROUGH
A 2020 ELECTION PRISM.
SINCE THE BEGINNING, ALL THEY’VE
DONE IS USE THE VIRUS,
POLITICIZE THE VIRUS TO BLUDGEON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ALL THE SAME PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DONE THE SAME THING FOR THREE
STRAIGHT YEARS.
IT IS SAD, IT IS NOT SURPRISING.
THEY’VE BEEN DOING THIS.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
UKRAINE, UKRAINE.
AND IMPEACH, IMPEACH ME NOW
CORONA, CORUNNA.
OR THE KILLING OF ALBERT
THE VERDICT IS IN ANDIMMEDIATELY
RALLY AROUND THE IMPORTANT FIGHT
OF WHAT’S A DEADLY VIRUS AND
DISEASE.
MAXINE WATERS: CALLING THE
PRESIDENT A LIAR WHO NEEDS TO
SHUT HIS MOUTH ABOUT
CORONAVIRUS.
YES, THEN COMPROMISE CORRUPT
ADAM SCHIFF CALLING THE
ADMINISTRATION INCOMPETENT,
"INCOMPETENCE KILLS."
OVER AT FAKE NEWS CNN, YOU HAVE
FAKE NEWS JIM ACOSTA, THINKING
THE PRESIDENT’S SPEECH WAS
RACIST BECAUSE HE SAID THE FIRE
STARTED IN CHINA PIER AND HERE’S
HIS OWN WORDS.
>> AT ONE POINT THE PRESIDENT
REFERRED TO THE VIRUS AS A
FOREIGN VIRUS PER THAT’S
INTERESTING BECAUSE AS I WAS
TALKING TO SOURCES EARLIER
THIS EVENING BECAUSE ONE OF THE
POINTS THAT PRESIDENT WANTED TO
MAKE TONIGHT, ONE CAN GET IT
ACROSS TO AMERICANS IS THAT THE
VIRUS DID NOT START HERE BUT
THEY ARE BE DEALING WITH IT,
IT’S GOING TO COME ACROSS TO
MANY AMERICANS AS SMACKING
XENOPHOBIA TO USE THAT KIND OF
TERM IN THIS SPEECH, CHRIS.
>> Tucker: FAKE MS. ACOSTA
ALSO REFERRED TO CORONAS FOR AN
ROUTES ON HIS OWN TWITTER IN
JANUARY.
YES, FAKE NEWS ACOSTA BY HIS OWN
DEFINITION, FAKE NEWS ACOSTA IS
A XENOPHOBE.
THE VERY SAME PEOPLE THAT WERE
INVOLVED IN EVERYTHING FROM THE
LAST THREE, EVERY SECOND,
MINUTE, HOUR EVERY DAY, THEY ARE
BACK WHERE THEY ARE NOT ABOUT TO
LET THIS CRISIS GO TO WASTE.
PUTTING AMERICANS IN DANGER.
THIS IS THE MESSAGE WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND TONIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO
PROTECT THE COUNTRY.
INSTEAD OF WORKING TOGETHER TO
HELP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU
HAVE THE MOB AND, OF COURSE, THE
RADICAL DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PARTY, THEY ARE WORKING
HAND-IN-HAND TO SMEAR THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE NOT SAID ONE GOOD
THING ABOUT WHAT HE HAS DONE.
NOT ONE!
CAN HE DO ANYTHING RIGHT?
THIS GOES AGAINST EVERYTHING OUR
FOUNDERS PUT INTO PLACE.
WATCH THIS.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT LAST
NIGHT, HE KIND OF WHIFFED AT HIS
TO CONVINCE AMERICANS THAT HE
HAS A PLAN OF DEALING WITH THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS HERE
DOMESTICALLY AND HE JUST SET THE
STAGE FOR JOE BIDEN TO WALK ON
AND THEN LOOK PRESIDENTIAL.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS?
WE HAVE --
>> HE MISSPOKE ABOUT THE
INTENSITY OF THE BAND AND THAT’S
ON HIM.
THIS COUNTRY IS BEHIND FOR
SEVERAL WEEKS.
IT’S ON HIM.
>> CHINA, IT’S WE KNOW THAT YOU
AREN’T
CAN YOU SEND BRIAN COMMITTEE
IT’S NOT JUST A RACIST DOG
WHISTLE.
IT’S A WHOLE RACIST ORCHESTRA.
>> Sean: HERE’S A QUESTION.
WHAT ARE THESE HATE TRUMP ACTS
HACKS, WHAT DO THEY WANT TRUMP
TO DO?
I CHALLENGE PEOPLE AT FAKE NEWS
CNN, "THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHICH
SELECTIVELY LIES EVERY DAY, WHAT
ARE YOUR IDEAS?
BRING THEM FORWARD TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PUT THEM ON THE TABLE AND WE’LL
WORK TOGETHER AND SOLVE THIS
PANDEMIC.
THE TRUTH IS NO PRESIDENT HAS
DONE THIS MUCH MORE ACTIVE THIS
QUICKLY THAN DONALD TRUMP.
NO PRESIDENT IN HISTORY.
HERE ARE THE FACTS OVER FEAR.
DECEMBER 30TH, AND ON THE
DISEASE WAS IN WILL HOLLAND
WUHAN, CHINA.THEY DIDN’T IDENTIF
CORONAVIRUS UNTIL JANUARY 7TH.
IMPORTANT DATES.
JANUARY 31ST, TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DECLARED A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY, AMERICANS
ABROAD WERE NOT SUBJECT TO
MANDATORY QUARANTINES ON
MILITARY BASES, HADN’T BEEN DONE
IN DECADES.
THE PRESIDENT ORDERED A TRAVEL
BAN FOR ALL NON-U.S. CITIZENS
WHO VISITED CHINA.
WHAT WERE THE DEMOCRATS DOING?
WHAT WERE PEOPLE IN THE MOB OF
THE MEDIA DOING?
WHAT WERE THEY DOING TO COMBAT
THE VIRUS?
THE QUESTION DOWN THE ANSWER IS
NOTHING.
THEY WERE INFATUATED WITH ONE
ISSUE, IMPEACHING DONALD TRUMP
LIKE USUAL.
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND CONGRESS ACTUALLY
SUGGESTING THE PRESIDENT’S
TRAVEL BAN WAS RACIST.
THE W.H.O. CHIEF, HE SAID THAT
RESTRICTIONS WERE NOT NEEDED TO
STOP THE OUTBREAK AND THAT THEY
WOULD ONLY INCREASE FEAR AND
STIGMA FOR THE GOVERNMENT OF
CHINA AGREED, ACCUSING TRUMP OF
OVERREACTING TO THE VIRUS.
OF COURSE, DEMOCRATIC PARTY’S
FRONT RUNNER QUID PRO QUO JOE,
WHEN THE PRESIDENT PUT HIS
TRAVEL BAN IN EFFECT, HE SAID IT
WAS IT WAS XENOPHOBIC AND
HYSTERICAL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IN MOMENTS LIKE THIS, THIS IS
WHERE THE QUIT ABILITY OF THE
PRESIDENT IS MOST NEEDED.
AS HE EXPLAINS WHAT WE SHOULD OR
SHOULD NOT DO.
THIS IS NO TIME FOR
DONALD TRUMP’S RECORD OF
HYSTERIA, XENOPHOBIA, HYSTERICAL
XENOPHOBIA, AND FEARMONGERING,
TO LEAD WAYS TO THE SCIENCE.
>> Sean: HYSTERIA?
ON THIS PROGRAM, DR. FELTY SAID
THE PRESIDENT’S TRAVEL BAN ON
CHINA PREVENTED AN UNTOLD AMOUNT
OF EXPOSURE AND SUFFERING IN
PLACE.
EITHER WAY, NEITHER BIDEN NOR
HIS COMRADE BERNIE SANDERS
SUPPORTED THE BAN.
NEITHER ONE OF THEM WOULD HAVE
ENACTED IT.
THIS ONE COURAGEOUS EARLY ACT
THAT DONALD TRUMP TOOK A LOT OF
HEAT FOR DID MORE TO PROTECT THE
SPREAD OF THIS DISEASE, THAT ONE
DECISION, JANUARY 31ST, 3 WEEKS
IN!
WHILE THEY WERE IMPEACHING THE
PRESIDENT, NOT DOING ANYTHING ON
CORONA, THAT ONE DECISION DID
MORE THAN ANY OTHER THING THAT
COULD’VE BEEN DONE, AND ALL THE
PRESIDENT GOT WAS CALLED NAMES.
IN FACT, LET’S LOOK AT SOME
PERSPECTIVE HERE.
BACK IN 2009, WE HAD A
BIDEN-OBAMA RECORD ON A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC.
THIS IS H1N1, AND I WILL USE
JOE’S WORDS, THE OLD
IN THE YEAR THAT WE HAD THE
FIRST YEAR OF THAT VIRUS,
60.8 MILLION AMERICANS WERE
INFECTED WITH H1N1.
NO TRAVEL BAN.
ONE IN FIVE AMERICANS GOT THE
DISEASE IN THE FIRST YEAR.
THAT RESULTED IN OVER 274,000
AMERICANS HOSPITALIZED.
NEARLY 13,000 DEATHS IN THAT
YEAR ALONE.
WORLDWIDE, UP TO 5.75000 PEOPLE
DIED
5,705
NO TRAVEL BAN, NO STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
IT WASN’T DECLARED UNTIL, WHAT,
OCTOBER, THEY KNEW ABOUT IT IN
APRIL.
ONE HEALTH ADMINISTRATOR DID SAY
IT WAS AN EMERGENCY 11 DAYS IN.
BUT NOT THE PRESIDENT.
NOT OBAMA.
AFTER A THOUSAND AMERICANS HAD
DIED AND TENS AND THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS CONTRACTED THE DISEASE
DISEASE.
THAT VIRUS, DESPITE THOUSANDS OF
DEATHS, MILLIONS OF CASES, THE
MEDIA MOB’S COVERAGE THE TIME?
WOW.
VERY DIFFERENT.
IT WAS MEASURED, IT WAS CALM.
THE MOB SUPPORTED THEIR
PRESIDENT.
THEY LOVE THEIR PRESIDENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET’S TALK ABOUT THIS,
SOMETHING THAT’S WEARING A WHOLE
LOT OF PEOPLE THESE DAYS, EACH
ONE AND ONE,
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA DECLARING
A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
SHOULD IT BE A WORSE-CASE
SCENARIO, ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS EMPHASIZING THAT IT’S
NOT THEY ARE EXPECTING ONE.
>> MORE THAN A THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN THE U.S. HAVE DIED FROM THE
H11 VIRUS, 90 IN THE LAST WEEK.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PREDICTED
THERE WOULD BE 100 MILLION DOSES
OF THE VACCINE, BUT AS OF THIS
WEEK AND 11 WERE AVAILABLE.
>> WHAT EXACTLY DOES THIS
DECLARATION MEAN?
>> PEOPLE SHOULDN’T PANIC WHEN
THEY HEAR THIS.
>> THEY RECEIVE TWO BOOSTER
SHOTS OF THEIR OWN.
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS DECLARED THE
FIRE IS NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
>> Sean: THAT WAS SIX MONTHS
IN, I THOUSAND AMERICANS WERE
DEAD.
TENS OF THOUSANDS CONTRACTED THE
DISEASE.
COMPARE THAT TO THE NINE ALARM
ANTI-TRUMP HYSTERIA ON RIGHT NOW
ON ALL DAY, EVERY DAY PRETTY
MUCH EVERY NEWS NETWORK.
LOOK, I UNDERSTAND.
PANDEMICS ARE SCARY.
NOBODY LIKES PANDEMICS.
NO ONE WANTS ANYBODY TO GET
SICK.
PEOPLE ARE SCARED.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
CANCELLATIONS, NO PROBLEMS
TAKING EVERY PRECAUTION
NECESSARY.
I UNDERSTAND THE CRITICISM, THE
TESTING KITS TOOK TOO LONG TO
COME OUT.
THEIR CRITICISM.
THAT’S BEEN RECTIFIED.
NOW THEY ARE BECOMING READILY
AVAILABLE.
THE CASE NUMBERS WILL RISE IN
THE SHORT TERM.
WE BELIEVE IT TO LEVEL OFF.
WE HOPE SO.
AS EVERYONE DOES THEIR PART,
HOPEFULLY WILL BE ABLE TO GET TO
THE OTHER SIDE OF ALL OF THIS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, ALL VIRUSES ARE
DANGEROUS.
SERIOUS STUFF.
MAKE SURE TO KEEP AN EYE OUT FOR
YOUR ORDER LOVED ONES, AND
GRANDPARENTS, PARENTS, THOUGH IS
HAVE UNDERLYING MEDICAL
CONDITIONS, IMMUNE COMPROMISED
OF SOME KIND, COPD, LUNG
DISEASE.
IN THIS COUNTRY, WE ARE NOT A
COUNTRY THAT LIVES IN FEAR.
WE ARE THE COUNTRY THAT TACKLED
PROBLEMS HEAD ON.
THE FACTS ARE THE FAX.
THREE WEEKS IN, THIS PRESIDENT
ACTED.
HE ACTED FASTER AND DID MORE TO
STOP THE SPREAD OF THAT DISEASE
THAN ANY OTHER TIME IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
TRAVEL BAN’S, BILLIONS IN
SUPPORT, FINANCIAL SUPPORTS.
ALL HANDS ON DECK FROM THE
GET-GO FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT ARE THE DEMOCRATS DOING?
THEY ARE IMPEACHING.
ULTIMATELY, THERE IS NO DOUBT
THAT WILL OVERCOME THIS DISEASE,
THE VIRUS.
AMERICA WILL COME ROARING BACK.
THAT’S A FACT.
AT SOME POINT, CHINA, THEY ARE